[Música]
bienvenidos al debate de france 24 soy
santiago lópez gonzález nuevamente la
atención entre rusia y ucrania aumenta
de manera vertiginosa mientras bruselas
washington y la otan miran con
preocupación una posible reactivación
del conflicto bélico en el este de
ucrania si rusia decide atacar
moscú dice que los planes de expansión
de la otan al querer incorporar a
ucrania y a georgia en esa alianza son
una amenaza directa para ellos veamos en
detalle la región de la que estamos
hablando allí donde se está
incrementando la tensión estas ucrania
una antigua república soviética es uno
de los países más pobres de europa y
apuesta por unirse a la otan y también
acercarse a la unión europea ambas
decisiones le han costado la presión
militar de rusia un país hermano con el
que comparte una historia milenaria
desde la fundación del arroz de kiev que
es prácticamente el punto de partida de
los pueblos eslavos en esa zona de
europa las regiones que ustedes ven de
donets y lugansk cuentan con una
población
étnicamente rusa en su mayoría y son los
puntos en donde se han dado los combates
desde que comenzó esta guerra en el año
2014 a lo largo de toda esa frontera en
estas dos regiones que tienen frontera
con rusia es donde el kremlin ha
desplegado las tropas recientemente al
norte pueden ver ustedes la ciudad de
hardcore que es la segunda ciudad más
grande de ucrania con un poco más de 1,4
millones de habitantes y al sur está
mariupol que es un puerto ucraniano en
el mar de azov que también ha sido
blanco blanco de ataques y de
incursiones militares en los
enfrentamientos que ha habido en los
años anteriores esa es digamos a grandes
rasgos esta zona en donde viene dándose
este incremento de tensión entre rusia y
ucrania
los nervios y la incertidumbre se
incrementaron a raíz de la presentación
en eeuu de un informe de inteligencia en
el que evidencia la aparente
movilización de tropas rusas hacia la
frontera con ucrania rusia así ha estado
muy activa haciendo ejercicios militares
en sus bases del sur del país muy
cercanas al mar de azov y también a las
costas del mar negro y también en el
báltico por el momento rusia no ha hecho
ningún tipo de comentarios al respecto y
de acuerdo al informe a unos 175 mil
soldados rusos aproximadamente fueron
desplegados a lo largo de esa frontera
ruso-ucraniana sobre todo muy cerca de
esos 145 kilómetros de largo que tiene
el frente de batalla abierto desde el
2014 se calcula que unos 100 grupos
tácticos de batallones fueron
desplegados para dar inicio a una
incursión militar aparentemente se
trataría entonces del doble de la
cantidad de batallones usados
anteriormente miles de tanques también
fueron desplegados a armamento equipos
militares fueron puestos allí en la zona
incluso fueron dispuestos equipos
necesarios para establecer una línea de
suministros desde el lado ruso
el lado del frente eso es lo que dice
este informe presentado en la ciudad de
washington
solamente cinco días después del
encuentro en estocolmo en suecia entre
el secretario de estado de eeuu anthony
blinken y el ministro ruso de exteriores
serguéi lávrov el presidente de estados
unidos joe biden sostuvo una
videoconferencia con su homólogo ruso
vladimir putin
washington no escatimó en advertencias y
la posible imposición de fuertes
sanciones económicas a rusia si llega a
atacar a ucrania por su lado desde el
kremlin afirman que la gota se muestra
extremadamente agresiva y con ideas
expansivas al querer incorporar como lo
decíamos a ucrania y georgia una
perspectiva que no le gusta a rusia y
por ello busca un pacto de seguridad
ante ese posible escenario de expansión
de la alianza atlántica pues bien para
analizar este tema esta tensión que está
incrementándose entre ucrania y rusia y
en donde también están allí inmersos
eeuu y la unión europea por supuesto
hemos invitado a pilar bonet a analista
internacional y periodista fue
corresponsal del diario 'el país'
durante los tiempos de la unión
soviética posteriormente en rusia y en
el resto del espacio postsoviético
durante unos 30 años
se une a esta conversación desde la
ciudad de madrid en españa también está
con nosotros alberto justo en haitã él
es el doctor en relaciones
internacionales profesor del instituto
de servicio exterior de la nación y de
la universidad abierta interamericana él
se encuentra en el hemisferio sur en la
ciudad de buenos aires en argentina y
aquí en el estudio de france 24 me
acompaña eric derramó la derramó lada ls
doctor en derecho y director de la
cátedra jean monnet de derecho
internacional e integración de la
universidad externado que está ubicada
en la ciudad de bogotá en colombia
ustedes también nuestros televidentes
pueden participar en este debate dejen
sus comentarios y sus preguntas lo
pueden hacer a través de nuestras redes
sociales no se encuentran en facebook en
instagram y en twitter estamos como
arroba france24 guión bajo es anti luego
que es mi cuenta personal la etiqueta es
numeral el debate 24 esperamos todos los
comentarios no inicio al debate
preguntándole a pilar bonet en la ciudad
de madrid si estamos verdaderamente ante
una escalada de tensión preocupante o es
simplemente un escenario similar como
esos tire y afloje
visto entre moscú y washington y que
ucrania simplemente está en la mitad de
estos dos bandos como lo ve usted pilar
pero primero a muchas gracias por
invitarme segundo no estoy en madrid
estoy en ibiza en españa pero en el
mediterráneo y un tercero o sea
creo que no hay que dejarse impresionar
por las movilizaciones
rusas efectivos militares
mientras estás no no no no pasen la
frontera y quiero recordar y me parece
muy importante que la guerra no empezó
hoy la guerra empezó la guerra
cruenta osea empezó en el 2014 y desde
entonces ha continuado y ha continuado
con altibajos con a veces de una forma
mucho más intensa a veces menos que lo
que se dirime hoy no es la guerra o no
la guerra que parece que es la pregunta
que importa a todo el mundo porque
incluso esta mañana vas a la a la tienda
y el tendero pregunta habla guerra o sea
bueno entender o que jamás se ha
preocupado por los temas de su cd en
rusia es decir lo que tenemos por es el
constante la distintiva entre seguir con
la guerra pequeña es decir que va
muriendo gente un goteo o sea pero que
no ha llegado hasta cierto límite y la
guerra grande que implicaría muchísimo
cómo puede acabar primero
otra cosa muy importante
desplazamiento desde tropas pro rusas a
la frontera y rusia ha estado presente
en la guerra de donbass sin tener que
hacer los
franceses esos grandes desplazamientos
importante por lo tanto y yo creo que
cabe preguntarse si el desplazamiento o
sea en la concentración por el momento
la concentración de tropas en territorio
ruso a lo largo en la frontera con
ucrania
un elemento de para el diálogo o es un
elemento de intimidación
para la guerra o ambas cosas a la vez y
yo me inclino a pensar qué es ese
desplazamiento de tropas es sirve a todo
sirve al elemento al diálogo sirve a
aumentar la atención y llamarte y
fijar hacer que uno se fije en lo que
puede pasar si sirve para las dos cosas
en este peso porque creo que uno debe
conservar la calma y la sangre fría la
guerra no la quiere nadie la quiere
fusión
si pilar
y pues vamos a estar analizando un poco
más en profundidad estos dos aspectos
que usted menciona pilar de la
intimidación y la guerra ya vamos a
tratar acabe de entender qué es lo que
busca el kremlin con esto y cuál es la
posición de eeuu y bruselas frente a
esto le hago la pregunta a alberto a
través de vía telefónica en la ciudad de
buenos aires- la misma pregunta es esta
escalada ya lo decía pilar lo decíamos
el conflicto está desde el 2014 pero ha
tenido altibajos y constantes
violaciones del acuerdo de minsk que es
como una paz incipiente que hubo ahí
entre los países implicados pero esta
escalada que significa que quien como se
puede entender
bueno yo creo que el conflicto en
realidad está desde antes de 2014 sucede
que el cierre de 2014 ocurrió un hecho
socio político deberían seguimos que el
político mayor que fue la amputación del
territorio de ucrania como consecuencia
de una decisión que se toma moscú
relativa con una posible deriva de
ucrania hacia una posición de antesala a
miembro pleno de la otan tales de manera
que a partir de 2014 la situación se
hace mucho más mucho más extensa y desde
hace dos años aproximadamente las
comunicaciones entre el gobierno de que
el idioma de moscú se fueron haciendo
cada vez más manzanas y la diplomacia
también descendió y rusia considera que
posiblemente esté ante un escenario pero
políticamente fatal para rusia pues
porque dulce tiene una concepción
básicamente territorial es un país
referencias políticas terrestres y si
ucrania llegar a ser parte de la está
convirtiendo al pleno yo diría que es el
tiempo de una segunda catástrofe
política de rusia puertos de rusia
perderían un activo protector y ccoo
mayor es la profundidad estratégica de
modo que yo creo que donde se está
jugando actualmente en ucrania es una
situación en la que moscú entiende que
quiere prácticamente ha dejado de lado
cualquier otra alternativa que no sea
convertirse en un nuevo miembro de la
otan pero esto para rusia que
inaceptable puesto que si efectivamente
pase a esto pues entonces putin salvando
las diferencias tu pin podría correr la
misma suerte que evaluación en relación
con la unión soviética salvando las
diferencias es decir en contracción fue
elegido para salvar a la unión soviética
y terminó haciendo responsables de la
caída putin si finalmente el plan ya
entró total sería responsable
impacto geopolítico sobre rusia sí y
aquí en el estudio de france 24 eric
tremolada y ahora sí lo dije
correctamente eric en su perspectiva su
opinión sobre esta escalada y esta
atención que hay ahora en este conflicto
que ya habían abierto desde hace varios
años gracias anti coincidido con
compilar y con alberto esto es una
jugada digamos pongámoslo en términos de
ajedrez ya que estamos en medio del
campeonato mundial de ajedrez es una
jugada de largo aliento y esto empieza
yo diría que desde el 2002 incluso
cuando es ucrania el primer país de la
ex unión soviética que hace el acuerdo a
la asociación para la paz con lo tanto a
partir de ahí en el 2005 y en el 2008
fue afianzando esa relación a punto de
solicitar la participación formal como
miembro del otan y recordemos de ser el
momento en que putin estaba haciendo el
enroque con medeved y en ese momento el
propio putin dijo o sea esto es lo más
grave que le puede suceder
rusia por tanto desde ahí se congela de
alguna manera el ingreso de ucrania ya
lo el 2014 es digamos una verdadera
escalada una verdadera escalada que el
tablero de ajedrez es ucrania donde
ucrania viene poniendo una serie de
costos
dentro de esa disputa que es básicamente
entre occidente entre la otan y rusia y
estos costos es lo que también
mencionaban los que me precedieron y tú
en la introducción y es el asunto de
donbass esta región separatista de
donbass con una mayoría evidentemente de
rusos pues de una u otra manera es una
guerra por personas interpuestas por
ejercicios interpuestos porque no era
rusia la que lucha son los separatistas
para los financian los rusos y esta es
una
guerra por boteo como señalaba pilar que
hay un manteniendo la idea en este
momento yo también coincido con ellos no
es realmente
escalar la situación sino
fundamentalmente
una jugada digamos saber quién quién
pone en jaque primero al otro y coincido
también con alberto que lo último que se
va a permitir
putin es que entremos a lota entonces
miren como parece que estudiamos en
escenario de pura guerra fría el próximo
jueves 9 de diciembre serán 30 años de
la disolución de la unión soviética por
un lado y por el otro lado de eeuu está
convocando la cumbre de países
demócratas les parece que estuviéramos
en el mismo juego donde lo que se está
disputando de una u otra manera es la
ampliación del otan o la contención del
otan eso es lo que está en juego y eso
es la amenaza de los 175 mil hombres que
están en la frontera una zona de dombate
y por supuesto también hay presencia en
el mar negro
yo lo introduciría ahí y eso es un
escenario similar a lo que vimos hace
unos años atrás en georgia que también
intentaba entrar a la otan y terminó
perdiendo dos son regiones société a paz
ya en un conflicto bélico con rusia
pilar en ibiza allí en las islas
baleares
empecemos analizando entonces la
perspectiva de moscú que está buscando
el presidente putin con esta jugada que
está haciendo allí en el este de ucrania
cuál es su opinión de lo que él se está
jugando
quien lo puede apoyar en estos intereses
que tiene el presidente ruso a nivel
internacional qué opinión tiene usted al
respecto
una vez creo que el presidente putin lo
ha dicho claramente lo que él quiere son
garantías de que la otan no va a
extender su espacio a las fronteras con
rusia que no va a extenderse todavía más
y esto concierne
claramente a
ucraniano pero por otra parte el tema es
que el garantizar quien garantiza
yo tampoco es que quien haya dado tantas
muestras de
que es posible fiarse de él y uno acaba
preguntándose qué fue primero si el
huevo o la otra gallina
y para poder resolver este tema es sin
guerra haría falta la creación de un
ambiente de confianza que no es nada
fácil
y que no está claro cuánto tiempo
llevaría es decir habría que desandar lo
andado y analizar con buena voluntad
qué pasó
desde ese
89 de diciembre de 1991 cuando los tres
dirigentes es largos
dirigían la redundancia a las repúblicas
de ucrania bielorrusia y rusia y se
pusieron de acuerdo en disolver el
tratado de la unión y se han pasado
muchas cosas y de aquellos polvos estos
ocho pilar y continuó con usted para
hacer la siguiente pregunta
podríamos estar ante un escenario
similar al que vimos hace unos años con
crimea es decir putin estaba a la baja
en popularidad y la anexión de la
península de crimea le representó un
incremento en su popularidad y en su
imagen dentro de la federación
entonces ya muchos rusos ya están
cansados de ser gobernados por él y ya
han mostrado síntomas de agotamiento de
una misma política prolongada por por
por casi tres o cuatro periodos
presidenciales y anexarse criminal le
representó popularidad podría
estaríamos ante la anexión del donbass
de donets y lugansk a rusia como para
volver a levantar esa popularidad del
presidente
bueno crimea tenía un valor simbólico
que no tiene el donbass eso es para la
historia para el auto la autoimagen la
verificación del pasado
primera tiene tiene otro valor donbass
es un activo envenenado y no solo para
rusia sino también para ucrania es decir
ucrania
no puede permitirse darle la espalda a
bombas porque no sabe
eso que un estado no puede hacer eso
pero
bombas es una zona industrial
totalmente decadente degradada
y que además tiene un unos votantes que
no son nada
nada interesantes para los que están en
el poder en ucrania y eso tiene una
importancia allí pero es que los
ucranianos se están muriendo por compás
creería
en una política inteligente porque de
hecho ha empujado a la gente de donbass
de bueno de lo de las autodenominadas
repúblicas populares de don jet ski y
lugares que sólo si una una estera parte
del territorio que está bajo control de
los pilares producto
si las ha empujado hacia rusia al
establecer un bloqueo en 2017 y
dificultaban místicos el paso de la
línea de la línea divisoria no sé y para
rusia lo sé tampoco quiere el territorio
de donbass yo no creo que esté
interesada en la adicción al lo tampoco
digo que no vaya a hacerlo pero
rusia
quiere mantener la atención entrar ya
entrando ucrania no sea no sea una parte
de
su sector
en tanto ucraniano ofrezca garantías de
no entrar en la otan a para el útil tu
te mantendrá el donbass como un elemento
de presión sobre ucrania
durante estos ocho años
alberto en la ciudad de buenos aires le
pregunto ahora por la otra cara de la
moneda y es eeuu y bruselas cuáles
pueden ser las intenciones de ellos lo
que necesitan allí para garantizar tal
vez la seguridad de ucrania que es un
país que se ha acercado a ellos
para tratar de protegerse de rusia qué
acciones pueden tomar washington y
bruselas
bueno el occidente parece resuelto a
seguir con la ampliación de los puertos
que yo considero que esta fue una
estrategia que precede a 2014 puesto que
si buscaría finalmente en avilés
alertante act y las ganancias relativas
de poder ser bien para rusia por lo
tanto la posibilidad de un punto de
vista de cerrar realmente el último
capítulo de la guerra fría sería una
ganancia relativa de occidente y
finalmente desde el punto de vista que
interesa no es cumplir lo territorial
básicamente la zona de amortiguación
territorial indicaría una relativa
ganancia también de moscú de manera que
una diagonal implicaría una relativa
victoria para occidente y una ganancia
de parados ya se habla de la posibilidad
de minsk creex es decir rusia considera
que eeuu de involucrarse más en la
cuestión diplomática y tratar de
disuadir
de marcar el cielo tan es decir que se
busque una situación en la que ucrania
no forma parte de ninguna alianza
atlántica que pueda quitar tener
efectivos de la organización sobre
cooperación europea en su territorio
pero que no forma parte de la alianza
atlántica porque esto no solamente el
inaceptable sino que si se llega a dar
posiblemente como se tienen en moscú
podrían aparecer nuevas líneas y esto
realmente no solamente es una catástrofe
sino que incrementaría sensiblemente el
nivel de inseguridad internacional si
otros países podrían sentirse amenazados
siempre los tres estados bálticos
estonia letonia y lituania se han
sentido amenazados por ser parte de la
otan y por tener una frontera con rusia
y por ese pasado que los une
durante la época de la unión soviética
erika aquí en el estudio de france 24
esto es como un sánduche digámoslo así
en un lado washington en un lado moscú
tenemos a bruselas por allí también
del lado de washington pero la mitad
está
qué opciones tiene ucrania entonces en
todo este escenario
ucrania básicamente es el tablero del
ajedrez en el sentido de que ahí se
disputa el escenario entre occidente y
en este caso los rusos
y de alguna manera también se está
buscando
hacer en la inmensa mayoría de los
gasoductos rusos pasan por el territorio
ucraniano pero parte de la estrategia
también es empezar a desviar los ya está
el norte stream el norte oeste en que
pasaría gas directo de rusia alemania y
esto es también parte de la presión esto
es parte de la presión o sea quitarle
relevancia en ese juego o crank y es
parte de la estrategia rusia rusa perdón
y por supuesto es parte de la estrategia
europea lo contrario subirle el
protagonismo a rusia a ucrania
y en este juego está el presidente de
alguna manera también selenski que
además
aprovechan internamente para cuestiones
políticas internas en ucrania este señor
que tengo que mirar el nombre porque es
impronunciable me topé que es uno de los
grandes empresarios días de la energía
en
ucrania de una medios de comunicación
además de alguna otra manera es prorruso
y la ley antiguo la oligarquías que
generó el señor selenski pues ha
generado una cantidad de presiones
internas y curiosamente parte de la
estrategia rusa es jugar por ese lado
para sabotear digamos al al gobierno
excelencia esto por un lado por el otro
presionando a europa está también rusia
con lukashenko con el asunto de
bielorrusia las fronteras la presión
migratoria y esto también está en de es
parte del juego por eso yo insisto esto
es más es toda una lógica de estrategia
es un juego de estrategia para tratar de
convencer y esto también es algo que es
casi sin salida para propio ucrania y
paracel en esquí en el sentido de casi
que se sienta un compromiso de que no
hago parte del otan es decir un país
renuncia formalmente a el uso de su
soberanía y de consentir participar no
en una organización internacional y esto
también es es casi una encrucijada que
pone todos en tela de juicio lo
preocupante es que no se ve que quien
quiera jugar no sabemos el resultado de
la cumbre esta cumples telemáticas que
si nos guiamos por la de la semana
pasada con china pues aparentemente los
resultados no son muy eficientes
entonces dentro de ese contexto uno
diría todo es una son jugadas moviendo
los peones y los alfiles para ver cómo
se van mejorando las posibilidades sin
embargo la preocupación es que con 175
mil soldados en una frontera en qué
momento la chispa se encienden y le
pregunto eric por el presidente es el
esquí este este jugador que está ahí en
la mitad de los dos grandes mitad
washington y en la mitad de de moscú qué
tipo de persona es a quien le juega a
quien le apuesta en qué parte del
tablero está cómo entender la posición
de celenque porque hay muchos intereses
como usted lo decía de empresarios
ucranianos con rusia y viceversa muchos
intereses rusos en ucrania y el
presidente está en el medio de la jugada
selenski es todo un personaje no no es
un político tradicional llegó con el 73%
si no me coco de los votos
era un comunicador básicamente y además
estuvo muy cercano a tromba en el en el
escándalo que generó el propio gobierno
de trump precisamente miren las
curiosidades para desprestigiar el hijo
de bailén en plena campaña de los eeuu
entonces todo esto nos hace ver que no
es un presidente fuerte no creo que sea
un presidente que tenga respaldo
político
digamos de las fuerzas políticas en
juego y eso también hace que este
escenario sea mucho más incierto va a
depender mucho de sus alianzas con
occidente y por supuesto el apoyo que
formalmente se lo pidió creo que el 25
de noviembre a bai ling en la rada que
es el parlamento ucraniano no cuenta con
mucho apoyo de las bancadas políticas en
su país pilar allí en españa las islas
baleares vamos ya llegando a la recta
final del programa para terminar este
análisis
la unión europea aquí que juega en este
tablero que hemos armado esta de este
juego de estrategias a nivel
internacional que juega la unión europea
y que puede pasar con bruselas y la
relación con kiev y moscú
bueno yo creo que
y no quiero ser dura porque pienso que
la situación es muy complicada que hay
muchos actores que esto es un juego de
combinaciones como múltiples resultantes
pero me parece que
[Música]
debería encontrarse soluciones más
originales más creativas ya cuando
las sanciones son lo que se puede
aportar
me parece peligroso no sean que las
sanciones no vayan a dar un resultado
tangible en términos económicos pero las
sanciones no van a solucionar es yo
francamente creo que habría que sentarse
en una en un tablero de ajedrez
y habría que ver cuáles son los
intereses
innegociables sea como como crear como
restablecer la confianza crear una
situación que integre intereses ipod y
vida no yo creo que el que ucrania esté
ahora a contestar creo que es una
tragedia para toda europa y en cierto
modo me alegro muchísimo de que el
tendero siempre
donde yo iba a comprar con artes de esta
manera se alegre muchísimo se pregunte
si va a haber guerra o no va a haber
guerra porque lo que pasta planea es
algo que nos convierte a todos a todos
hasta aquí esta isla esta pequeña isla y
tiene importancia y yo creo que habría
que aportar
todo lo que uno puede para que no
hubiera guerra desgraciadamente que los
políticos están jugando con varias
barajas y no sea y eso es intolerable y
tóxico que estamos tanto así política
irresponsable
no quiero hacer gestiones de acciones
pues a nadie son distintas pero todos
son unos verdaderos
irresponsables seprelad obviamente a
rusia ucrania
todos
pues tan importante es esta escalada de
tensión que lo estamos analizando aquí
para américa latina que está a miles de
kilómetros de lo que pasa en el donbass
y aquí estamos tratando de entender cuál
es la situación allí alberto en la
ciudad de buenos aires- en el pilar dice
que esto pasa por la creación de
intereses comunes entre las partes puede
haber acercamiento entre moscú y
washington y washington para bajar esta
atención esta videoconferencia entre los
dos mandatarios terminó siendo un sartal
de advertencias por parte de washington
hacia hacia moscú y moscú diciendo yo
tengo que defender mis intereses y voy a
hacer lo que tenga que hacer para eso y
pueden ponerme todas las sanciones que
quieran pero voy a seguir defendiendo me
pueden crearse esos intereses en común
bueno siempre es importante que los
conversando como
siempre es mejor que no pero yo no
encuentro un foco irreductible al
conflicto puesto que la diplomacia se ha
alejado desde niño links 2 ha quedado
muy atrás y ellos mirando consecuencias
de victorias pequeñas pero limita el fin
de georgia en ucrania en la zona
mediterránea mental en siria etcétera
considera que este es un momento para
presionar y por eso están aquí entre 100
y 150 millones en la frontera oriental
de ucrania de un espacio para la isla
pero yo creo que hace falta como vínculo
final una asunción de responsabilidades
en general yo considero desde el punto
de vista que aquí la primera piedra
ha rondado occidente al ir más
les conozcan había que llegar a un
equilibrio político y soltando por la
letra de la historia
occidente fue más alta e incluso en
contra de lo que es de lo que sugerían
real e insospechados idealistas como el
mismo que nana en 1997 que desaconsejó
la ampliación de los campos y conocía el
sentimiento territorial de rusia de
manera que el mismo kissinger para tomar
estas posiciones esté autorizadas no de
manera que hay un espacio para la
diplomacia aún se habla de la
posibilidad de renovar minsk y un
involucramiento mayor de la unión
europea y estados unidos pero no en
relación con llevar un plan era tan
porque esto para mí es inaceptable para
mí es inaceptable así lo ha dicho moscú
varias veces
eric digamos ya la parte final del
programa hagamos las conclusiones qué va
a suceder en este escenario bola de
cristal para saber el futuro no tenemos
siempre lo digo acá al final del
programa pero que cree usted que pueda
suceder en esta situación sin hacer
prospectiva en relaciones
internacionales es casi que un salto al
vacío
yo creo que digamos de aquí al final de
año solo vamos a seguir viendo un juego
geoestratégico de tensiones de
declaraciones en general según los
servicios de inteligencia americanos la
invasión a la supuesta invasión estaría
preparada para el donbass hacia los
primer la primera semana de enero
y
lo único claro en sanciones que le
dolería a rusia y que se hizo ya
evidente con la telemática de la reunión
telemática hoy entre biden y putin sería
la de los códigos swift y el código
swift los códigos iban estos que me
permiten las transferencias bancarias
que bloquearían pues totalmente todo lo
que tendría que ser transacciones en ese
sentido para rusia y eso sí le dolería
pero claro escalar esto a sanciones como
bien dice pilar pues esto termina siendo
irresponsable donde todos están jugando
una lógica de soberanía como en él como
en un orden internacional previo no sólo
ya la guerra fría es incluso al de la
segunda posguerra pues estamos casi que
en lógica estado céntrica plena donde
todos quieren mostrarse soberanos
fuertes y poderosos eso hace que sea
absolutamente incierto el futuro se me
acaba el tiempo
ya me quedan pocos segundos para
terminar a erika que en el estudio
alberto y apilar en las islas baleares
les agradezco por haber estado con
nosotros haber hecho este análisis para
la audiencia en américa latina
describiendo las conclusiones de
nuestros dos invitados pero se me acaba
el tiempo ya debo entregar porque sigue
el noticiero ustedes muchas gracias
pueden seguir viendo la programación de
france 24 y dejen todos sus comentarios
y preguntas sobre este tema sigan con
nosotros
[Música]